we are recording right now you're doing
are you excited
very a lot of things okay well Monday is
here on it's great we troops it's great
it's great
Ron its grace what's up its crews yeah
Monday's here need to be a whole lot
sexier I'm barely fresh London no maybe
maniacs six different no one do sir it's
sexy Monday's okay but I appreciate your
brainstorming right now that it's a
beautiful day no need for storms spoiler
alert
we have been drinking mildly because I
shot a video over on his channel and
that's what Sawyer's a son his children
part of Fifty Shades of Grey but now
we're over here and we're playing
married unsubscribe used to be 32 right
but this is the YouTube servants of
Crocker people I've never heard of this
game and it's originally her kill
there's basically three human choices
and you can decide between those three
people who you would who he would marry
and in this case who you would
unsubscribe from and I have created a
winner yeah a list of trios and the
thing that has to happen here is that we
have to answer as fast as possible you
can't think about anything at seven
rooms these are call this group the
sweethearts I just seen Felicia Day or
missglamorazzi Arianna subscribe right
away unsubscribe Felicia Day Mary
iJustine sorry
[Music]
I just beam sorry Ingrid Tyler Oakley
Joey Graceffa Troye Sivan oh Jesus Mary
Joey Graceffa Troye Sivan I have sexual
relationships with a young boy but yeah
and subscribe
Tyler Oakley just cuz of how mad he
would get marriage for Sivan I would
sorry Joey subscribe the next day don't
worry about it Phil DeFranco Kassem G
Smosh I would Smosh at meri Kassem G and
I sorry Phil what's up Anthony how you
doing buddy haven't seen you in a while
like the Tony for sure I know me too
but he's already good stays subscribe to
source fur
yeah there's much worse in that's fine
hey this thing is Phil's getting married
and getting we know that that's
happening stuff oh he doesn't need that
I slept in when the cold doesn't need
Kingsley Shane Dawson the entire o2l
house oh Jesus I would marry Kingsley
Shane and then would have done this back
even though my first choice is different
but then I realized
like 17 and then 17th of push the hood
shits up flourish like that's being like
oh I'm sure she reads into college-level
like that's a push very Shane Dawson
because he's funny
I guess Kings really would get it and
I'm gonna subscribe to that soft I don't
feel like being made like a shish kebab
right there's like six of them this is
do us for this duo's Manor we
tag-teaming yeah oh Jesus I'm at where
you stand
the brothers right now Oh God the block
oh okay oh no oh no it's here who would
you please call her out on Twitter yeah
that is not true the thirst is real I'm
parched
just being in my own a dehydrator I'd
marry the brothers right now
is it friggin awesome yeah oh we like to
charter the vlogbrothers you mix up Finn
Jack and love us yeah and I knew that
you lied because you have a pervert side
whoa you wanna see more of it perfect
site go watch the video
the link will be on his face are down in
the description below and it got weird
real fast
it is comfortable with a lot you are
wearing handcuffs you're bit of ugly I
don't know there's one more
Meehan oh there's more 1y with me have
worse than magic than enough last one
myself Hannah mamrie oh god I would
marry man right you could get it and
handle enough to get on subscribe but I
love you
mamrie marry Hanna unsubscribe from
myself you don't watch your videos
anywhere I'm the humble human being